Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Would You Rather.
Now, we're gonna be rolling right along- I was looking for other settings,
like in 'Will You Press The Button' that could make a change up,
but all the best that I could do, is create an account that can log up all of my answers.
So hopefully we'll get some new ones, and hopefully we'll get some fun ones.
So the first one!
"Would you rather only speak in haiku or only speak in song lyrics?"
Now this one would be great,
because I could end every sentence
with "It's snowing on Mt. Fuji."
And that's all I would ever do, and no one would ever question me.
So I'll take the haikus.
AWWW! Oh no... that would be much smarter.
Oh... because there's a lot of words in song lyrics.
OHHHHH...
That'd be way smarter!
I'm stupid! I have to end every sentence with
"It's snowing on Mt. Fuji!"
I'm a fucking idiot!
Goddammit! Okay.
"As a leader,
would you rather be loved,
or be feared?"
I mean...
Usually it's not a choice.
BUT AS A LEADER I'LL TAKE BEING FEARED!
*Evil laughter*
Okay, anyway...
"Would you rather die on The Hindenburg,
or die on the Titanic?"
So either die in a fiery explosion,
or die in the frigid waters of the Atlantic.
These both don't seem like very good choices.
Uh... uh...
I guess maybe The Hindenburg would be quicker?
I don't know?
I don't know!
Nyeeeeh okay.
Ohhh god, no one can decide. *laughing*
"Would you rather wear only skin tight clothing,
or wear clothes that are much too big?"
I guess skin tight to show off my epic bod?
Wh- of which I have.
And I guess, show off the rest of me.
Ugh, that wouldn't be too good. *laughs*
I don't- good thing you guys can only see me from the
waist up because ordinarily,
I'm naked from the waist down..
So, I'll take the skin tight clothing, thank you very much.
"Would you rather be Lindsay Lohan,
or Miley Cyrus?"
Oh...
I have no idea.
I'm not good enough to judge this situation.
I mean on the one hand,
Lindsay Lohan's career is kinda on the way down,
Miley Cyrus is still riding a little bit of fame...
She also got to ride a wrecking ball naked.
I... Lindsay Lohan did a lot of drugs..
*indecisive mumbling*
HGNNNN
PEOPLE ARE GONNA JUDGE ME FOR THIS!
*indecisive high pitched scream*
"Would you rather be the best singer in the world... but ugly,
or be the worst singer in the world... but beautiful?"
Okay.
Now, there's a lot of good singers out there,
but you're so incredibly bad.
Like, you're- you're so bad.
Literally!
The worst singer in the world!
That's like a marvel, unto itself.
I mean ordinarily, I don't sing anyway.
And you could have a choice...
not to sing.
But if you're so bad, like,
it's like what I always say:
If you're gonna fail, fail as hard as you possibly can.
Make it such a big failure,
that people will write about it for years to come,
and always talk about it.
So I'll take... I'll take the bad singing.
"Would you rather slam your hand on top of a thumbtack with a half inch pin,
or shoot yourself in the top of the foot with a nail gun?"
OHHHHHH....
OW....
I'll take the thumbtack that seems like it'd do less damage, I- I guess.
Okay.
"Would you rather take a cold shower every day,
or take only hot showers just once every two weeks?"
Now, see, cold showers are good for you.
They actually are. Like, uh,
the whole- there's a whole science about...
exposing your body to temperature variations and stuff like that
but cold showers, are honestly, good for you.
They suck!
They suck ass!
And also...
Only taking hot showers once every two weeks...
*cough* is truer than some might think and truer than I would like to admit
because I'm a disgusting slob!
Who lives alone... and has no one to care for me!
I'll take the cold showers..
"Would you rather drink and drive,
or smoke and fly?"
Now, see, it's not being very specific here.
It is just generally smoki-
I could be on fire and flying.
Not that that's a better option.
But I would take anything as opposed to drinking and driving.
"Would you rather be a hawk, or be an eagle?"
Well... I don't really have any stock one way or another in this question.
I guess I'll take...
EH...
Y'know what I think everyone would be an eagle,
but hawks, hawks are cool.
I'll take the hawk.
I'll be a hawk..
Even though eagles probably can eat hawks...
Yeah whatever, I'll be a hawk.
"Would you rather have your hands switched for dustpans or be sweating jam instead of sweat?"
Well, both of these are bizarre!
How the fuck did...?
Hands are dustpans?
And sweating jam is such a bizarre thing!
I- I actually don't think I'd mind sweating jam.
*laughing* I could make a living off of my own personal jar jam.
Ohhh god...
How many of you would buy...
one: a bottle of my sweat...
and two: a bottle of my sweat if it was a jam?
I'll take the jam, please.
"Would you rather have two sets of twins or quadruplets?"
Does that mean I'm a part of this?
Or I have children that are this?
Y'know, if- if I had to decide...
Quadruplets are super rare, so...
I'll go with thaaat?
Because that's really bizarre and interesting?
Not that I wanna subject my children
to being freaks of nature,
but...
NOT SAYING QUADRUPLETS ARE FREAKS OF NATURE OR TWINS!
PERFECTLY FINE!
I'm just saying how... rare and interesting it'd be.
Alright, whatever I'm movin on before people hate me.
"Would you rather not be able to taste, or not be able to smell?"
Oh, man.
See, food is such an important thing.
I think I could go through life not being able to smell anything.
But if I couldn't taste food anymore...
That would be.. that would be tragic.
OH NO!
NO I MEANT THE OTHER ONE!
*high pitched screams of mistakes made* OH NO!
I MEANT TO CLICK THE OTHER ONE!
Ohh, I'm stuck with it forever.
Huh dammit...
"Would you rather hang out with Pooh Bear, or hang out with Baloo from the Jungle Book?"
Now I don't know. They're both bears,
one's bigger than the other,
one would also mean I live in the jungle...
I don't know. I've always liked Winnie The Pooh.
I think he's cool...
I think he's a cool guy..
"Would you rather catch your best male sleeping with your mom,
or catch your best male friend sleeping with your sister?"
Well...
I don't have a sister.
But....
At least that one would seem more logical?
Because that COULD happen in real life?
I mean...
I- I don't really have anything one way or another, but..
I mean, I wish my mom all the happiness in the world I guess but...
I think it'd just be less bizarre if I found my best friend sleeping with my sister.
I guess?
And also I don't have a sister?
Let's see..
Oh, Nintendo DS or PSP?
Now, this is where my opinion differs probably from a lot of people,
because I bought a Nintendo DS.
I don't have one on the regular.
I bought it...
And I was very upset because I hadn't bought a DS since like
the old silver flip one?
And, I bought it... AND IT DIDN'T COME WITH A CHARGER!
LIKE THAT SEEMED LIKE THE MOST RIDICULOUS THING!
DID THEY NOT EXPECT ANYONE TO COME INTO THIS NEW?!
LIKE I HADN'T BOUGHT IN YEARS!
AND A PSP... admittedly the battery is just ass...
But, at least that came with all the necessary accessories.
I don't even know if they make PSPs anymore.
But I HAVE to choose the PSP, because Nintendo screw me over!
"Would you rather be a vampire who can transform into a bat, or be a ghost that can possess only appliances?"
WHAT'S THE DOWNSIDE OF THE VAMPIRE?!
Isn't that like a normal function of the vampire?
Although being a ghost and only possessing weird appliances-
Oh man.
What if robots eventually become an appliance and I get to haunt them?
Ooohhh I likey. I'll take that one
You know what? I'll do that.
Because... I don't know.
Vampires are boring and for scrubs..
Give me the ghost that can haunt a toaster any day.
"Would you rather lose an eye and a hand, or lose a leg and an ear?"
Huh.
An eye and a hand...
I can wear a sweet eye-patch and have a hook for a hand.
Or, have an artificial leg and lose an ear.
Well, I mean you could get a prosthetic ear pretty quickly and just because you lose the ear doesn't mean that
you lose th- the sense of hearing.
Plus, I could have a peg leg.
Can I lose the eg- the leg and the eye? And then I'd be a really cool pirate?
I'll take the leg and the ear.
"Would you rather eat a pie, or eat a grape?"
PIE! GIVE ME THE GODDAMN PIE!
"Would you rather get an Atomic Wedgie, or get a Swirly?"
Now, if you don't know what an Atomic Wedgie...
it's a wedgie, where they pull your underwear,
so far up,
that it
reaches up over your head.
And then you're blind, walking around with your balls inside of your 'A-nus. '
And that's no good for anybody,
so I'll take the Swirly.
*disgusted noises*
WHAT?!
PEOPLE WOULD WANT, AN ATOMIC WE-
DO YOU NOT KNOW THE DEFINITION OF AN ATOMIC WEDGIE!?
AN ATOMIC WEDGIE
IS SO MUCH MORE WORSE
THAN A NORMAL WEDGIE!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
NO WAAAY!
"Would you rather only eat breakfast cereal, or only eat pasta?"
Well, questions. You have landed on the only two things I EAT in life these days:
Instant microwaveable pasta,
and frickin' cereal.
This just shows, how SAD, my life has become!
*"crying"* Don't judge meeee.
"Would you rather have stretchable legs, or stretchable arms?"
Okay, this is where things get real bizarre.
Because, you can either reach out and punch people,
or reach out and grab the soda from across the room which is more like what I would do.
I would snake my arm all the way downstairs to the fridge and grab something to eat
and pull it back up. Probably either pasta or cereal one of the two.
Or, you can have stretchable legs, and you can kick someone really far away.
Or, you can look like you're walking on stilts as you go around town.
I'll leave this one up to you.
So choose. I don't know which I'd pick, but you guys know which one you'd pick.
So write down in the comments below.
Thank you, everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see YOU...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BUH-BYE!
(first video) "Whee... Okay..."
"What's with all the poopy clouds?"
"Poopy clouds don't look-"
(second video) "Hi, I'm Woody!"
"Howdy, howdy, howdy!"
"I almost said, Woody, Woody, Woody!"